la première question est ce qu'on peut
me raconter un peu ce qui s'est passé à
bahreïn vendredi alors dans la nuit de
vendredi à samedi alors que j'étais
couché on m'a appelé pour me signaler
qu'il y avait des jeunes qui rôdait sur
la commune donc avant d'appeler
systématiquement la gendarmerie je
constate et un petit peu les faits j'ai
fait le tour du village avait rien
d'anormal donc je me suis arrêté en
boudant bout de village pour voilà
quelques quelques minutes et c'est alors
qu'un véhicule est arrivé assez
rapidement et s'est positionné derrière
moi et que une altercation est intervenu
très rapidement sans que gens
comprennent les tenants et les
aboutissants ce vous avez filmé c'est ça
la scène est ce qui s'est passé après
alors c'est un réflexe que j'ai quand
j'ai un doute sur une situation afin de
me protéger parce que je commence à
croire que la parole d'un élu à un point
de valeur qu'avant je filme justement ne
serait ce que pour relever une plaque
pour pouvoir me défendre en tout cas si
nécessaire c'est les moyens qui nous
responsables et qu'est ce qui s'est
passé concrètement alors je ne peux pas
forcément donné toutes les tous les
détails
des altercations parce qu'une enquête
est en cours et c'est important qu'elle
soit qu'elle soit menée de manière
impartiale
je me suis fait agressé par un individu
qui à mon sens était atteint de démence
et malgré le fait signalé que j'étais le
maire de la commune en tout cas ça n'a
pas ça n'a pas réduit la puissance des
coups physiquement on voit un peu sur la
vidéo c'est violent effectivement
c'était violent verbalement physiquement
je confirme et puis ça se voit
maintenant sur sur vous suivent oui les
traces apparaissent mais bon il ya aussi
derrière enfin possiblement à un
traumatisme psychologique
et c'est aussi une lassitude ou
d'instituts et parce que cette situation
elle peut être récurrente c'est régulier
se retrouver face à des avis division
qu'ils soient habitants ou non qui sont
plus en plus agressif avec les forces de
l'ordre ou avec des ellipses ça vous
étonnez que même en disant que vous
étiez maire il soit vous avez quand même
agressé oui parce qu'on peut considérer
que voilà il ya une prise de conscience
en dix ans doit faire attention je dois
pas faire n'importe quoi passer un élu
mais vous ça vous étonne ça me surprend
plus pourquoi parce que aujourd'hui il
ya plus forcément de de respect en tout
cas de ligny forme ou de la fonction